[Music]
I'm Keith Olbermann and this is the
resistance 60 days into his presidency
and there is only one possible
conclusion Donald Trump is a loser
amid the kaleidoscope of the last two
months of prejudice hatred revenge
gluttony dishonesty potential corruption
proto fascism corporate state ISM this
this is perhaps the only unexpected
development the only true surprise these
people are idiots what in fact have they
thus far accomplished they have left
such a bad taste in the mouths of their
own supporters that the gallup tracking
poll showing as late as the 25th of
January that Trump approval was at 46%
and disapproval at just 45 has now
collapsed to approval at 39 and
disapproval at 55 with control of the
White House and the Senate and the house
they got an intelligence hearing Monday
that confirmed the FBI is investigating
the nature of any links between
individuals associated with the Trump
campaign and the Russian government they
have a Republican member of that
committee and the Republican deputy
Majority Whip both insisting Trump owes
Barack Obama an apology for Trump's
wiretap hoax story they have Trump still
propagating this hoax even as it roots
back through an uninformed Fox talking
head to an anti Michelle Obama
conspiracy theorists with ties to the
Russian propaganda network RT and they
not only still can't get Trump to let it
die but Trump tried to draw the German
Chancellor into supporting his paranoid
delusion at a news conference and she
looked at him like he was a dick they
have let Trump attacked the Free Press
attacked the intelligence community the
judiciary protesters the opposition
party and the vote totals in an election
in which he prevailed they have let
Trump go out in public day after day and
setting after setting acting as if he is
not a governmental executive working for
this nation but is the owner of a
company and we are all his employees and
if he doesn't like what we do
he will fire us they have produced a
budget
rule draconian stupid medieval and yet
have somehow managed to lose the
narrative on it so badly that it is
actually perceived as worse than it
actually is they have set out of
profoundly an exhaustingly stupid man
named Mick Mulvaney the budget director
to publicly explain cuts by saying quote
can we really continue to ask a coal
miner in West Virginia or a single mom
in Detroit to pay for these programs
unquote without ever thinking that
people would respond by wondering if
it's okay to ask that coal miner or that
single mom to pay the more than hundred
thousand dollars a day it costs to keep
Melania Trump living in New York City or
to pay the approximately three million a
trip it costs to let her husband go play
golf nearly every weekend nearly every
goddamned weekend they have so little
idea even how to manipulate public
opinion that they have done little to
refute the conclusion that this budget
eliminates meals on wheels for the
elderly and veterans when it does not
but the damage has left Trump looking
like Scrooge in A Christmas Carol asking
are there no prisons are there no
workhouses they have tied themselves to
gutting health care changing their own
promises about insurance for everybody
to access to insurance for everybody and
then finally to know nothing for
everybody they have said an amateur
dressed up as a secretary of state into
the middle of a hornet's nest in North
Korea and China and when the story gets
out that he canceled a dinner cuz he was
fatigued they cannot refute that story
because they themselves banned the press
except for one lone conservative website
from accompanying him on his trip they
had a National Security Advisor resigned
and proved to have been a paid
representative of the government of
Turkey while he was receiving classified
American intelligence and of the
Government of Russia only a year before
they've had an attorney general
misrepresent the truth that his own
confirmation hearing and must be forced
to recuse himself from key
investigations they've had a senior
adviser come under scrutiny for wearing
a purportedly pro-nazi anti-semitic
Hungarian medal and tunic to an
inaugural ball they have tried and
failed twice to impose a Muslim
and with Trump's own words and the words
of his minions being quoted back at him
by the courts who stopped him they have
insisted that the ban could not wait a
day let alone a week for implementation
but then they waited for weeks to
introduce the revised version they have
been so a mature --is-- using those
entry laws that they already do have
that their operatives have twice
detained the son of the legendary boxer
Muhammad Ali and they have kept for
questioning the former police chief of
Greenville North Carolina whose first
name happens to be Hassan they have been
so ham-handed at the border that they
publicly advertised that they would
separate or begin to separate toddlers
from their parents at detention centers
perhaps they have reportedly threatened
to deport a man with a Hispanic name who
was born in Puerto Rico they have
staggered from insisting the border wall
would be paid for entirely by Mexico to
insisting them to be paid for by us with
reimbursements from Mexico to explaining
it would be started even though they
reportedly only had enough on hand for a
mile or so of law under their
inspiration The Secret Service has
become so dispirited or incompetent that
it had a laptop full of Trump Tower of
floor plans stolen were found to have
had agents who took selfies with Trump's
sleeping grandson and needed 17 minutes
to find a fence jumper at the White
House they have been so slovenly about
security that passers-by at Trump's
mar-a-lago resort were able to
photograph him formulating a response to
a North Korean missile test and last
weekend one Gawker boasted of eluding
the Secret Service there in order to
take a selfie with one of trumps endless
series of portraits of himself they have
done all this in just 60 days these
people are idiots this is no longer
merely about Trump's substandard and
dysfunctional mental psychiatric or
intellectual status this is now most
urgently about his unadulterated and
unceasing incompetence and the
unadulterated and unceasing incompetence
of those he has brought with him into
government this is about the
by his opponents and by his supporters a
realization seemingly growing
geometrically every single day that the
worst case trump scenario is going to be
the standard operating procedure until
we remove this incompetent and unstable
individual from office and rush to save
this nation while there is still a
chance to do so resist piece